now then the next thing i notice is that
in this result that i'm trying to prove
up here
right not everything has a conjugate
over it so i need to try and remove some
of these
now some are easier and some are harder
let's have a look for example
at these guys over here c and 0. the
thing about c
and zero is that based on the way this
question was defined
zero is always just a real number
there's no imaginary component to it no
square roots of negatives flying around
and c they've told me right from the
outset c is a real number
so the conjugate of the complex
conjugate of real number there's no
imaginary part to plus or minus
or you could say that the imaginary part
being plus or minus was
0i that is to say that if you've got a
real number
you know for x which might happen to be
a
real number the complex conjugate of
that
is equal to the number itself right
because
um if you've got that plus
0 i minus zero i doesn't change your
number okay
so therefore i can say uh while my focus
initially was on separating that this
out into
several pieces i can now say
that these guys out the front will just
stay put for a moment
like so and then the conjugate of c
the complex conjugate of c will just be
c since c is a real number
and the complex conjugate of zero will
also be zero
okay so um this is good this is progress
um you can see i'm edging closer to you
know what this is
supposed to look like this looks good
this looks good now i just need to sort
of tease out what's happening
here okay now there's two things left to
deal with
the first is i noticed that um see that
b and that a
they don't have bars over them right so
i'm not including them or i don't want
to eventually include them in the
conjugate
now just like i noticed that c is a real
number um
i can see right up here a and b are also
real numbers
so what is the relationship between um
a conjugate of a real multiple of a
complex number
with the you know the conjugate of the
original number
well let's go with this let's go back to
z right z equals x plus i
y let's suppose i should separate these
properties out a little bit so this one
here
that's the sum of the conjugate of a sum
rather
and this one here is just you got a real
one there okay good
so now what i'm going to consider is
what about when you have
a real multiple sorry i should do it
here a real multiple
of a complex number what happens when
you take the conjugate of the whole
thing okay
well i'm going to take z i'm going to
just multiply it by a real number let's
go
you know k z
if it's equal if k is just a real number
um it's going to be
k times x plus i y
and i'll just i'll just put k being a
real number
over here okay well i'm just going to
expand out so you can see that's just
going to be k
x plus i k y
nothing dramatic but what this does let
me do let me do rather
is i can now take conjugates of both
sides the conjugate
of k multiplied by z by definition i'm
just going to take this imaginary part
and i'm going to flip it sign over
right so that gives me kx out the front
minus
i k y okay
that's nice but how does this relate to
the original
complex number z well what i can say is
if i
you know i expanded out that k i
distribute it to everything now if i
factorize it back
you can see i'm getting k outside of x
minus i
y which by definition i keep saying that
is
k times z bar that's that's the
conjugate there right
so what have i just shown well if you
take the conjugate of a real number
multiplied by a complex number you can
essentially
just say that's the real number
multiplied by the conjugate you don't
need to have that conjugate part
over your real coefficient okay so
how do i use that fact well here let's
be uh let's be lazy
again here you can see that when i'm
having a look at
uh this a which is a real number
multiplied by the complex bit
it doesn't need to have that bar over it
i don't need to
take the conjugate of a because the you
know a itself is after all just a real
number and i don't have to do it for b
either so i'm going to erase that part
there okay
so things are looking good i'm going to
bring this this conjugate this bar a
little lower so it's closer to that
omega
things are looking really good right if
i compare this this line here
with the result i need to get there's
literally just one last thing right
i've got um b times omega bar that looks
good i've got
c that also looks good i've got the zero
the last part is just
in here okay so how do i deal with this
how do i go from the conjugate or the
square
how does that relate to what i want to
get
well let's take our our z right and
let's let's see what happens
if i say let's square it what what
result does that give to me
well i'm going to go let's see here it's
x plus i
y squared which is equal to i'm just
going to expand it
so that gives me x squared plus
2 i x y now
i'm going to write plus i squared y
squared just so i
i'm trying to prove this result here
this property so i'm not going to skip
anything
but i do notice that i squared is
actually
negative 1. so really this this y
squared terms belongs over here as part
of the real component
except it's not plus it's minus y
squared okay so there is the real
component and then i've got this
plus two i might as well just factorize
out that i out the front to make it
really obvious that it is the imaginary
component so that
is n squared so what happens when i take
the conjugate
of this well the conjugate of a
square is equal to uh nothing happens to
the real part so i'm just going to
copy that but with the imaginary part it
becomes a
minus like so
okay now um how does this help me well
if i do the same
trick that i've been doing this whole
way along which is to undo the steps
that i did before
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
expand this all out and see if there is
some i can backtrack and do a
factorization right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say this is just x squared minus y
squared
minus 2 i x y now if i put that
minus 2 i xy in the middle
you might recognize that this is a
perfect square right
you've got your this term squared this
term squared and this is double the
product of those right
this is in fact x minus i y
squared but that thing that's being
squared that's the conjugate of z
right that's the conjugate of z there
all
squared and that is equal to the
conjugate
of z squared so what are we just saying
here the conjugate of a square
equals the square of the conjugate so
that's kind of nice so what that allows
me to do if i come all the way back here
is to say this term i can substitute it
for
the conjugate of w that's being squared
the conjugate of a square equals the
square of the conjugate
and uh and then the rest of it is
unchanged so i'm just going to duplicate
that so take a breath what have we just
done right
you can see on the right hand side here
i have been just sort of using my
definitions of a conjugate and some
basic algebra
to show these properties of a conjugate
right
that the uh in this first line to the
second line
that i can break up that conjugate of a
sum into the sum of the conjugates
from the second line to the third line
the conjugates of real numbers
are just the real numbers themselves um
from
line three to line four um a real
the conjugate of a real multiple of a
complex number is the real number
multiplied by the conjugate of just that
complex part
and then lastly um the conjugate of
square equals the
square of the conjugate so this at last
is the result that they were asking me
to prove here okay
a times w bar sorry
omega bar squared plus b omega by plus c
equals 0
looks pretty good okay so part c
what have you just proved about the
complex the two complex roots
of the equation think about this for a
second we already knew from the
beginning that omega was one of the
complex roots of the equation
and in part a we used that to show that
therefore
this equation is true but we've now
written
an equation just like it except instead
of omegas in here and here you can see
i've replaced the omegas
with omega bars i've replaced omega with
its conjugate
now what that means is if this is true
then omega
bar the conjugate of omega satisfies the
original
equation this one just like omega does
right
so omega if that's a solution then or a
root i should say then omega bar will
also
be a solution and we had to use
everything we had to use our properties
of
conjugates and we also had to use the
fact i referred to it
more than once right that a b and c have
to be real
otherwise you know this doesn't actually
work out we couldn't do say for example
this line see this
you can't just say that c bar is equal
to c you can only do that
if c is a real number and you can only
go from line three to line four
and just sort of take this out and not
apply that conjugate for the same
reason so what we can say is
if if a
b uh if a b and c
are real then
this quadratic equation is z squared
plus b z
plus c will have
two roots it's always going to have two
and those two roots are going to be
complex conjugate complex conjugates i
should say
will have complex conjugate roots
so if you've got these real coefficients
a b and c then this will be the result
and in fact
like i promised right at the beginning
this particular result actually has an
important name it's called
very imaginative the complex
conjugate root
theorem uh because it is always true and
we have just proven that it is always
true regardless of the values
of a b and c or indeed omega omega can
be anywhere
but if omega is a root then omega bar
will also be a root
uh the complex conjugate of it will be
your solution as well
so hope that makes sense this is an
important result
it appears in the syllabus even if it
doesn't get named like this
and you can see we had to use our logic
and properties very carefully
in order to prove it